hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and ah
i'm just checking there on you what's
going on everybody
old freckles has a busy week i'm
recording this on wednesday
so all you laker fans out there if you
think i'm skirting the issue that you
won number 17
if you did congratulations if you didn't
go miami
that's all i can say
in this new nba of the last i don't know
20 something years
whatever i'm just a grumpy old man you
know i was i was actually thinking about
all of this crap where people just look
at how the game isn't played though
oh yeah the 10 best people all pile on
[ __ ] two teams
it's the most boring [ __ ] it's not it's
not as bad as i'm making it out to be
but
i will say this in defense of myself
remember that you that olympic dream
team
that everybody still blows to this day
right the jordan lead dream team
that was the most boring basketball i've
ever seen in my life
other than the clip of when jordan's
team was playing magic johnson's team
during practice
that was the dream the dream game but
watching you know
[ __ ] guys all of those guys playing
against ethiopia and winning by 126
points
it was like watching the jocks play the
math team
you know i'm i don't watch vince carter
jump over some [ __ ] nerd
i mean how long can you i don't know
i'm not into that [ __ ] so but that is
how the game is played and the boston
celtics play it too
so it's all fair right we bought one in
2008 they're better at buying one so
good on them if they want if they didn't
uh go miami that's all i can say
all right plowing ahead here um
the real thing that i want to talk about
is
uh the passing of eddie van halen
the just i don't know there's no words
i don't know what to say i really don't
but i'm gonna try here
um i always remember when i was in high
school
um and some of the teachers i had
who were teenagers when the beatles came
out
and uh you know even if you told them
yeah you know i like the beatles and
everything it's like no no you don't get
it there's no way
to you had to be there to understand
what it was like when they came out
how exciting it was when their next
record came out and how much
they changed pop music and all of that
type of stuff
and and and that is a really true
statement because the longer
time goes by when the giants come
through you know since their debut the
more people
take from what they did and it waters
down
um you know what
the impact of what they had initially
because i will tell you this obviously
i'm not old enough
for the beatles but i i will tell you
that
the first time i heard van halen won
their first
album um there was a family down the
street like we were all into ac dc but
there was a family down the street from
us that were in
it was two of them were kind of like our
family big families
five boys and then there was another one
that had like three four boys and a
bunch of uh
sisters and stuff just big families and
so their brothers were a little bit
older so they were hip to the music that
was coming out because i was still like
in like
i don't know third fourth grade but the
first time i heard that [ __ ] album
it was like it was like nothing i had
ever heard before in my life
it was i was telling dean delray it was
like the record was like i was surprised
the record wasn't on fire it was just
this
sound i had never heard in my life
it made the hair on my arm just stand up
and what was so cool about back then
was there was no video there was nothing
you just had the record and you're just
staring at the record like
what is that how does somebody make that
sound is that more than one guitar what
is going on here and
um i always feel like people that are
that far ahead of their time
in inevitably they're just misunderstood
when people then try to replicate or try
to figure out what it is that they're
doing
um and i feel like he was unbelievably
like misinterpreted where people
finally figured out his tapping
technique
and then the way they applied it they
didn't have his gift
and it would just be sort of you know
take a solo and play nine million notes
where if you listen to eddie's
just his phrasing that the [ __ ] ride
the guy took you on he had the ability
to play 90 million miles an hour and but
just because you can do that doesn't if
you do it
all the time it or for a
too long of a time it loses its effect
so the way he would like pull it back
and then at the precise moment just
unleash
that fury and then he could go and then
take it back down again go into like
this melodic
just the [ __ ] ride that that guy
could take you on in
in two three i mean eruption was like
barely two minutes long
all the way up to like he could write a
music score
six seven minutes long just um i'm so
thankful that i got to see him
in concert i saw him uh i missed those
guys the first time around
so when they got back together with
david lee um
i got to see them with uh eddie's son
wolfgang on bass i saw him at the
staples center
and um my favorite part of the show
other than that dave was back with them
you know
uh was there was an instrument when
eddie took his
solo and it was eddie and alex and i was
just sitting there like
i don't know i couldn't believe how good
they they still were cause i don't know
people just have it in your head where
you know you get older
you know you lose the fire or the
passion or you slow down or whatever
they were [ __ ] unbelievable then it
finally just dawned on me
that like wait a minute these guys have
been jamming
these are brothers they have been
jamming and writing
and interacting with each other
musically
at that point for close to 50 years
and it's weird i don't remember what
they played i just remember
sitting i was to the uh right side of
the stage
up a little bit just sitting there my
mind [ __ ] just going they still
they're actually better than they were
[ __ ] we're in the 80s so
um i don't it's a huge huge loss
to my generation and all that and all
young people who don't know who he is i
highly recommend starting with van halen
one and just working your way through
um and uh my condolences to you know
obviously his whole family and uh
you know it just sucks man this whole
[ __ ]
getting old thing and all that so there
goes another one holy [ __ ]
last [ __ ] 10 years i think of some of
the people that uh
that went a lot of whom i never saw
cause
i don't know i went to a lot of sports
and metal [ __ ]
like i saw david lee roth's band with
steve vi greg bissonette
and billy sheen and i did see that uh
the eden smile tour um i wish i went to
more concerts but yeah i didn't have the
[ __ ] money
i would have gone to more if i could
have but i'm thankful for the ones that
i saw
the legends i saw i got to see eddie van
halen i got to see malcolm young
um i got to see stevie ray vaughan i
mean those are three big ones but
you know and i highly recommend just
even if you didn't get to see him and
whatever when they were younger you
should go see when they're older if
because
they're still doing it and like you know
unless they've just completely fallen
off and [ __ ]
then it's sad you don't want to see that
[ __ ] but like uh
you know i'm still kicking myself i
remember prince came to the forum and
did like [ __ ] 20 shows
and i didn't go see one of them i was
just on the road and i was wiped out and
i just assumed that he was gonna be
around again
um david bowie i never saw all of these
people so i am
just so thankful that i just got to see
a guy that just turned the guitar
[ __ ] upside down he was like he
literally was like an
alien and um
i don't know like i i to this day
i i just feel like uh
you know like alex van halen i still i'm
waiting for him to get his dues how
great a drummer he was like his brother
just cast such an
incredible shadow and just how humble
alex must be that he was cool with all
of that and he just didn't like i got to
tell you something that
i was talking to my buddy the other day
about well yesterday when this whole
thing went down when i was talking about
we were just talking about uh you know
vinnie and dimebag and then now you know
eddie and alex
and just that brother bond
drummer and lead guitarist type of thing
and um
we were just talking about how you know
the drum parts vinny paul came up with
and the stuff that alex van halen came
up with and i remember actually got to
meet and get to know vinnie a little bit
such a nice guy when i did the rich uh
the rich [ __ ] tour
with the late great charlie murphy uh
don l rawlings and he came out and
he just was such a nice guy answered all
of my questions
and uh i remember i asked him i said who
did you listen to and everything and he
brought up alex van halen
obviously his brother dime was a huge
eddie fan
you know obviously so um
i imagine vinnie was too but like that
he brought up
alex van halen i was like i love this
guy because like i just always feel like
you know when you talked van halen it
was about eddie's playing in dave's
front man skills uh but the song that
always just blew me away
was um uh mean streets
and that was yet another one when
that thing came out it was just like
what the [ __ ] is that guitar part what
is he doing
how does he do that i remember like like
[ __ ] seven years later i was living
in north carolina for like a year
and i was working at this restaurant and
was this really cool dude
jason was his name worked at this
defunct [ __ ] restaurant the sable
cafe
in cary north carolina we worked in this
was [ __ ] hilarious i got so many
[ __ ] stories about that place man
just the coolest funniest craziest
[ __ ] people
um i mean it's the restaurant business i
don't care how elegant
it is out in the [ __ ] room you got no
idea what's going on in the kitchen
uh just say people were feeling good
you know i don't know if i ever told
this [ __ ] story
um all right
so part of my job was i had to [ __ ]
mop the floor in the beginning it was uh
i might have told this before on the
podcast but this is just one of my
favorite just [ __ ] random
stories i was i actually told it
yesterday to somebody
just fresh in my head i guess so they
had this this oyster bar
it was one of these these restaurants it
was like in in a i don't know what
carries like now but it was like a it
was an up-and-coming
sort of suburb and they built this
five-star [ __ ] restaurant
and put all of this money into it i mean
it was just hemorrhaging cash from they
needed to be sold out from day one which
is one of the toughest things
to do in any business forget about a
[ __ ] restaurant
but that's what they did so they had
this oyster bar
um and it had the black and white tiles
like the
an improv or something back in the day
and so every night every morning i would
come in there
and just those black and white tiles
would get so [ __ ] filthy
from people spilling drinks and and food
and the dirt on the bottom of the shoes
it just looked horrible and i would come
in there
and i have to pull all the chairs out
and um
[Music]
i don't know i'm a [ __ ] lunatic like
i i don't i always just had like
i got into it it's like i'm gonna
[ __ ] have this thing
like shining [ __ ] it if i gotta do this
i'm gonna do it right my parents taught
me that so i'm [ __ ] doing this [ __ ]
and then
i'd get it it was like a horse-shaped
shoot uh shaped bar
i'd start to the left and i would work
my way around and then
the dreaded part when i get to the other
side
i kind of have to leave it uh i would
wait to do the last part
um until the end because people would
come in and they would
be walking in the kitchen as they were
showing up to work so i would
mop up three quarters that and then the
worst part is i had to go into the
bathroom
because now i had to go do the bathrooms
in the [ __ ] bathrooms the [ __ ] that
went on there i
no pun intended i will tell you the
woman's bathroom
i don't even i don't know what the [ __ ]
they did in there but it was like they
had a ticker tape parade
with toilet paper and then they
eliminated on it lipstick and just
[ __ ] it was literally like a bunch of
rodeo clowns threw [ __ ] at each other
it was makeup and just i don't know what
blood i mean it was a [ __ ] crime
scene in this so i'd do that one
last so i go into the men's room
and i'm going into the mop up and my
boss
is in there when i tell you just [ __ ]
ralphing into this he's got the water
going
and he's brushing his teeth and he's
just
and after each time he would continue to
brush his teeth
and then for another few seconds and
then just go
in the sink and i was just literally
standing in the door trying to process
what i was seeing and then
he was done i mean this this whole thing
went down in like [ __ ]
eight long seconds it was like two to
three
massive like were you possessed by the
devil [ __ ]
yaks into the sink
while the water's running and he's
brushing his teeth between each one of
them
not looking at me and then when he's
done he just turns around and he says to
me
oh yeah you know just sometimes i gag
when i brush my teeth
it is how dumb i was i [ __ ] believed
him
i it wasn't until like i don't know like
eight nine ten years later i thought
about it again i was like
no he was [ __ ] hungover he was
hungover he either started to brush his
teeth and whatever he did the night
before was coming out
or i don't know i mean am i really
supposed to believe that
what are you jamming the whole [ __ ]
tooth you deep throating it
like a porn star um
i don't know so anyway this is a long
story gets me back to [ __ ] mean
streets
so then i would finish that area in
there and
and then the place was slowly going out
of business and as it went out of
business i've told these stories before
i went from being the bus boys
slash mop things up to busboy slash mop
[ __ ] up slash dishwasher
slash grill shift i ended up doing like
three of the [ __ ] jobs and they just
kept bumping me up like 50 cents 75
cents an hour and i should have been
like well wait a minute you were paying
me six in a quarter to do this and you
were paying that guy seven bucks to do
the grill
if i'm doing both i should now be making
13.25 an hour right
i was just happy to get i was so [ __ ]
bad with money
i was so [ __ ] bad with money i was
doing three jobs i was a busboy a
dishwasher
i was also mopping up what the [ __ ] am i
mopping up for that's a cleaning company
that's not my job right well maybe it is
i'll give them that one and then the
grill i should have been getting pulling
three [ __ ] checks
they just kept giving me [ __ ]
quarters and i was like oh wow
i do this for another six months i can
buy a symbol
um maybe even a zildjian so
i got to know the metallica dude
jason right and and his brother played
guitar and they hung out all of them
were like [ __ ]
full-on metal heads long hair the whole
[ __ ] thing
ripped jeans the whole 80s look and i
went over his house one day hanging out
and a bunch of them were over there
playing guitar and they could really
these kids could really [ __ ] play
and one of them remember he had the
bleach blonde hair
and he sat down and played the beginning
of mean streets and it just
[ __ ] blew my mind like how did you
figure that out
i didn't that's all i was thinking i
didn't want to say anything
so um like most people just before i
even started playing drums so like most
people
so i guess i wouldn't have been thinking
that i would buy a cymbal i don't know
what i was thinking
um but whatever but about a year later
because watching them and then i
came back to boston area started working
in a warehouse and i was playing
i was working with all these musicians
and [ __ ] i got into playing drums
that's how it all started so and then
that began
my first listening of van halen then
listening to alex
like the first 9 000 passes through
i was just listening to eddie and
wishing
you know fantasizing that i was eddie
you know the [ __ ] like i was playing
this in front of my fifth grade class
you know the dumb [ __ ] you do right
um and then i started playing drums and
that's when it's so crazy i went back
and re-listened to all of these albums
and i discovered the genius of guys like
everyone from phil rudd all the way you
know to um
alex van halen and what alex plays
on that if you put it on
that offbeat thing that he's doing on
the bass drum and how he just
does it he
and like he crack i think
i think he crashes on the end and then
it's just
it's boom
the whole [ __ ] song until they go
until he does a little fill
and this is home and then he's on one
and then
don't don't get that go don't go i don't
know how the [ __ ] he does that
and stays on time
and then also makes it groove as hard as
it does like those two guys
um with the passing of eddie the fact
that those two
like their body of work just the two of
them forget about
michael anthony in there david lee sammy
and everybody who's been in that band
it's just it's um yeah it's an
absolute uh end
of a a true giant and just looking at
like the people that uh
that like from just a wide variety of
people
everybody from comedians all genres of
music
um country everything and you know those
country players like i swear to god
some of those guys like way back in the
day when i used to watch like roy clark
there's no [ __ ] way
a guy like eddie looks at roy clark and
doesn't see like that those guys you
know blue grass guys those guys could
still can't shred so there's i that's so
cool to me that there's that mutual
uh respect and then one of my fav other
favorite guitarists of all time
jeff beck uh i read a quote now this is
the internet so you don't know
the internet is not the library the
library actually puts [ __ ]
in fiction and non-fiction right
the internet everything is put in
non-fiction
so allegedly
i read this quote that's just some
random person put up that jeff beck
allegedly said i want to thank eddie van
halen for re-inventing the guitar
um which is you know as high a
compliment as you can
i think just as far as the the
musicianship
of jeff beck so just as a fan and a hack
drummer i just like to thank eddie for
all of that
unbelievable uh beautiful
face melting music that he put out
for so long and was literally
like this it got me through so just so
much [ __ ] it just always put you in a
good mood
as you were growing up no matter what
you were going through those ben you
know you got your bands and that was uh
that was one of mine
so rest in peace man that's a
uh you're not gonna see another guy like
that i mean
there'll be another great one but the
greats are always unique so
um rest in peace eddie van halen all
right
so with that old freckles
i gotta go to work here i don't have my
advertising yet
um i've been having a great time in new
york here
working out these sets and i actually
feel like i'm getting stronger as a
comic
um i was talking to a couple of young
bucks last night
comedians and and buckets whatever you
called
and um i was just saying like at first i
was really frustrated
trying to work out my stuff for this gig
um
that i was doing it in front of eight
people on a rooftop or
out on a sidewalk and blah blah and then
it's actually it's taking me back
to the earliest parts of my career where
i would be psyched to have a gig
and i would do gigs like that for free
and it's so funny it's like the gigs you
get when you first start as a comedian
you you almost need to be a master to
actually
make the it work because the situations
you're put in
are so impossible it's like from day one
you are thrown into places where you
need seven to eight years experience
just to emotionally handle the
humiliation that you're about ready to
put yourself through
and uh but what happens is is with each
one of them
you know with that graduation class of
open micros that you come up with you
guys lean on each other
and you start telling stories about
bombing and how embarrassed you were and
how dry your mouth got
and those are the things that keeps you
going
and um and then i guess that point where
you start to get in better gigs and you
know
how to write jokes and then now that you
have jokes you got some
ammunition you go in there and you learn
how to get these people to listen
you learn how to not get affected by a
trickle of laughter
and to try to turn that trickle into a
little stream and then try to build it
and build it and build
it and um
and then you get those skills and then
you get the experience and you combine
the two
and that's when you start getting good
but then what happens
is when you get to a certain level and
you start selling tickets
it goes from going on stage and having
to get the crowd
to now the only thing you have to worry
about is losing them
because they came they paid to see you
they want to see you they're on your
side as you're walking to the stage
so during that period i've always felt
that you get a little bit weaker
because um it's easier
in that you already have them but
there's also
a new pressure where it's they have
expectations
so that's there's always something new
that you have to kind of push through
but um anyway this pandemic
has now brought me back to those types
of gigs
and when i tell you i was [ __ ] eating
my balls here
thursday friday saturday this week into
sunday
and i was just in full panic attack like
oh my god
he's [ __ ] new york i was actually
blaming the crowds in new york
that's a classic thing to do as a
comedian if you don't want to get better
it's their fault it's not me
everything i'm doing is perfect i had to
i just had to remember to have fun
and uh
and just you know not let that little
trickle bug me
so all of a sudden then sunday night i
went up and i actually just had fun and
all of a sudden
the whole thing just clicked and started
you know
started killing with it so i was very
excited about that
and um
i don't know i don't know that's that's
that's just basically what i've been
doing i'm trying to uh
get this [ __ ] thing together here for
this gig so
that is it um looking forward to maybe
if i get a chance if i'm not too busy
watching thursday night football this is
the first rematch of tom brady in nick
foles both on new teams tom brady on of
course on the uh
tampa bay buccaneers and nick foles uh
is on the bears
via the jacksonville jaguars and you
know people are actually giving this guy
[ __ ]
like what do you have to do and how
often do you have to do it before people
respect you i mean people
you're good three weeks oh what you mean
when he won the [ __ ] super bowl
did you ever have three weeks like that
there [ __ ] oh
all right that's it um
that's it rest in peace eddie van halen
and uh
that's it that's all i got to say man
what a what an absolute
genius and uh thank you for sharing your
gifts with everybody
all right the advertising everybody all
right candid company
you know all the things we love to do
for ourselves but haven't done
we haven't done it for whatever reason
well you've always wanted to straighten
your teeth
and get a better smile hey stop putting
it off there crooked chops
thanks to candid straightening your
teeth is simpler
easier and more comfortable than ever
candid clean
clear aligners are comfortable removable
and practically invisible unlike wire
braces
you know you got force gump legs on your
teeth you don't want that
so you can transform your smile without
anyone noticing
all right plus your treatment is
prescribed and monitored remotely by a
licensed orthodontist
who's an expert in tooth movement
well that's what an orthodontist is it's
going to be monitored by a plumber who's
an expert in
unclogging sinks and it's all done from
the comfort and convenience of your own
home
candid only works with orthodontists
well thank god that's what they do
never general dentists like other
companies ooh
shots fired plus your supervising
orthodontist will be with you
every step of the way yeah you don't
want a dentist near these guys going to
like yank your teeth out this guy's
going to straighten them
with candid your treatment includes
remote monitoring by the same
orthodontist who created your plan
so you never have to wonder how how
you're doing you'll always know
the average candid treatment is just six
months you'll start seeing results way
before them and it costs
thousands less than braces come on
people you got to straighten your teeth
put a big smile on your face straighten
uh stat straightening your teeth today
right now
all listeners can save 75 dollars on
candid static kit
go to candidco.com and use the code burr
that's candidco.com
let me spell that out a n d i d
capital c capital o dot com slash bur b
u r r
code bur take advantage of this limited
time offer to save seventy five dollars
on your static kit
com candidco.com bur code burr oh so
earlier oh it's it's not candid company
because it's co period i don't [ __ ]
know chief petty officer i don't know
all right policy genius everybody but
it's halloween this month you can hear
all the gay people cheering
it's halloween this month and policy
genius would like to mock the occasion
by making some
something less scary home and auto
insurance
shop for insurance shopping for
insurance can seem like a daunting task
but policy gene just makes it easier
they combine a cutting edge insurance
marketplace with
marketplace with help from licensed
experts
to save you time and money policy genius
saves their home and auto customers an
average of one thousand
one hundred twenty seven dollars a year
by shopping top rated insurance
by shopping top-rated insurers in one
place here's how it works i'll tell you
what's not working
me reading out loud today all right
first
head to policygenius.com and answer a
few quick questions about yourself and
your property
then policy genius does the rest they'll
compare rates from
over 30 top insurers from progressive to
nationwide
to find the lowest quotes their license
experts will look at all the ways to
maximize your savings including
bundling your home and auto policies if
policy genius finds a better rate
than what you're currently paying
they'll get you switched
for free uh that kind of service has
earned policy genius a five
star rating across over 1600 views
on trustpilot in google so if you are a
homeowner
head to policygenius.com right now to
get started they've saved their home
owners and auto insurance customers an
average of 1 127 a year
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
i'll tell you as much as i [ __ ] up the
beginning of that i crushed the ending
all right oh look who it is legal zoom
everybody
monica stocks monica starks could relate
she needed to hire for a pivotal role at
her construction company
gs group who's what's the pivotal role
the guy writes the the [ __ ] breakfast
order on a shingle
sorry but having a tough time finding
the right candidates out there so she
switched to oh it's sip recruiter
it's not legal zone why do they have
that they she she switched all
zip
[Music]
zip recruiter doesn't depend on
candidates finding you it finds them for
you
it's technology identifies people with
the right experience for your job and
actively
invites them to apply which is why you
should try
ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com that's how
monica found lamont you big dummy
jenkins
uh lamont your big dummy she said that
zip recruiters sent lamont's profile to
her for around
five minutes after she posted her job
because he was a great match for the
role
through zip
monica's company has hired everyone from
accountants to project managers to field
scientists but monica's not the only
employer who loves zip recruiter
four out of five employers who post on
ziprecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day okay you get it you
have a pivotal position
at your company you don't have a lot of
time to fill it four to five
employers who posted on zipper crew to
get a quality candidate within the first
day see for yourself
how's it go
makes hiring faster and easier try it
right now for free that's right free
at ziprecruiter.com that's
ziprecruity.com
all right that's it that's been the
podcast for today uh
please enjoy the music uh picked out by
the one always wonderful andrew
themeless and then we have a bonus half
hour
of a thursday afternoon our greatest
hits thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast from a
year ago 10 years ago i don't know how
it works i don't even think i've been
doing thursdays for 10 years who knows
andrew knows all right god bless you
have a great weekend you can't
all right i'll talk to you guys on
monday
oh my god look at you you're flush you
just don't look like you're yourself
right now
you're scaring me here go in the bedroom
no
just go in the bedroom just lay down
drink plenty of fluids
i don't know if you guys are like me but
i [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] when you get
sick and then somebody tells you just
gotta shut it down
and you just have to go in there and
[ __ ] lay there bored out of your
[ __ ] mind it's like why can't i be
sick doing [ __ ] i have to lay here or
just be like ugh
i'm [ __ ] sick while you come in here
bringing me cups of tea
see that's your problem i just want to
help you and you won't let me do it
um as you can tell echo i'm back in new
york
in my apartment
um and if elected
there will be no more common cold
as long as you have the money to pay for
the cure
if you are below the line go [ __ ]
yourself
you didn't buy a 5 000 plate to donate
to my campaign
um i'm [ __ ] spent
i feel like [ __ ] i thought i was going
to cough again then those cops would be
like the backup dancer to what the [ __ ]
i was saying
um i finally got sick man i'm [ __ ] in
the middle of a seven week tour
i'm five weeks in this [ __ ] finally hit
the fed
when i was out there in cincinnati uh
i don't know what happened you know what
it was
is this [ __ ] global warming is is
[ __ ] with me
it's just everybody is is it's
summertime
until well into [ __ ] october not even
well in you know what i'm saying
and then bam it just becomes like deep
in the fall
so i [ __ ] show up in cincinnati after
looking at the forecast i show up out
there with like a windbreaker
right and uh just the first night i got
this [ __ ]
i have no jacket on i'm tired from my
[ __ ] ninth flight of the [ __ ]
month
and uh you know it was raining out
and then that was it oh and then what
else bill what else
dumb thing did you do did you take any
vitamin c
i don't even know if that works what did
you take what did you do
nothing i didn't take anything i shook
hands and then [ __ ] rubbed my nose
with the hand i shook everybody's hand
with and then that was it i was [ __ ]
sick
[ __ ] sick so i get to new york city
no that's not even what i do so [ __ ]
versi dude i called it
verzi [ __ ] tells me to get that uh
that airborne
you know take the [ __ ] that everybody
else has taken you know
throw the exact same punch that this
[ __ ]
virus has seen over the last [ __ ] you
know whatever
five years you think you can't see that
coming at this point
oh the old airboard the old triple lindy
the 23 skidoo [ __ ] slips that and
then punches me right in the face go
[ __ ] yourself
you're sick for three days so that's the
deal
all right um
so what do i do i get here to new york
this this podcast is going to suck by
the way so
i warned you four minutes and 11 seconds
in all right so it's your fault if you
don't [ __ ] tap
out you're probably going to keep
listening aren't you sadistic sons of
[ __ ]
um so i go out and i'm like all right
i want to sleep i want to sleep tonight
and just [ __ ] try to get ahead of
this goddamn thing so i go to the
goddamn
what is it the cvs the dwayne reed
whatever the [ __ ] it is rite aid
i don't know what part of the country
i'm in well i know a part of the country
but i forget what they have
so anyways i [ __ ] go in there and i'm
looking for the alka-seltzer cold
and [ __ ] flu [ __ ] right
and i just start reading the stuff on
the back and it basically says if you
take this four times in one day you're
gonna do
major irreparable damage to your liver
you understand how [ __ ] up that is
okay four times it just takes
four doses of this [ __ ] and i'll do
major irreparable damage to my liver
why the [ __ ] would i even take it once
you know what i mean that's like having
a gun instead of holding it to your head
you shoot your foot why the [ __ ] would
you do that
so i was like [ __ ] that [ __ ] that
alka-seltzer
i'm gonna tough it out and then i
pussied up and i got some [ __ ] nyquil
but even then i read this one and this
one has it's some [ __ ] long-ass word
begins with an a and it has like 17
consonants in the word in a row you know
like a [ __ ] russian hockey player's
last name you know
czy is the first [ __ ] three letters
of their weird ass names
um and it all says that it does [ __ ]
liver damage so i'm sitting here old
school
toughing this out like a [ __ ] quaker
you know they do that [ __ ] out there in
pennsylvania that kid gets an
appendicitis and they're like well why
would we just go to the [ __ ] witch
doctors
when they know how to [ __ ] handle it
we'll just sit here and go ooh
and [ __ ] hold our hands over it
rubbing our hands together you know like
you're in karate kid
and then the kid [ __ ] dies
that's what i'm saying i'm trying to be
the first adult who dies of the common
cold
and it'll be my silent protest to the
[ __ ]
or whatever ah jesus hang on
oh left-handed from across the room
right in the [ __ ] bucket
so anyways this is the podcast for this
week i got a huge
i got a huge week a bunch of bunch of
promo stuff my special came out last
week
for download five dollars are whack and
um
pretty much there was you know i would
say 99
success rate with people downloading it
i want to thank everybody that's been
downloading it please tell your friends
to continue it's a nice steady stream
um it was like you know one percent of
people had difficulties their computers
or the thing you know who knows what and
they were all very nice there was only a
couple
[ __ ] emails where i had to get up and
walk around
here's one if if you had a problem and
you want customer service
it's probably not good to start your
email off with seriously
seriously like i give you five dollars
and then like i seriously
uh what a [ __ ] [ __ ] i had somebody
else go right
i love how like nobody ever thinks hey
maybe it's me maybe it's my computer
like when i'm telling you 99 of the
people are getting a special without a
[ __ ] glitch
okay and i have empathy for people who
go to download something that doesn't
work out that happens to me every time
all right but i know that i suck at all
things computers
okay but i had a computer whiz set this
[ __ ] up okay so this one guy
hits me with like um
he was just so convinced that no one was
gonna respond to him
that he just went [ __ ] all in and
evidently he came up with this theory
that i was basically not giving anybody
this special and i was using it
five dollars each to just buy a new roof
that's what i was gonna do i was gonna
[ __ ] everybody over
[Laughter]
completely like napalm the little fan
base that i have
just you know for the short run to get a
new [ __ ] roof
you know it'd be one thing if i was
sending out hard copies this is just a
[ __ ] digital thing you know i don't
have to keep pressing a bunch of them
you just get access to it you download
you know i don't know why the [ __ ] would
i do that so i just wrote the dude back
i was just like listen
just a glitch you know we'll make sure
you get the special if you'd like a
refund i'll you know
send me your address i'll send you a
check the [ __ ] is wrong with you but
even his was funny
it was a dude wrote seriously
seriously like i i have to like download
this too to like watch this
seriously ah oh and then the other
[ __ ] there was like three [ __ ] this
week and i out of like a couple thousand
people
there was only three [ __ ] another one
[ __ ] wrote
tried said you know this is the fourth
time i
[ __ ] emailed you which was a total
goddamn lie
or they don't know how to send a [ __ ]
email because i was like you know
i don't know what the word is i wasn't
saying religiously or [ __ ] whatever i
was making sure because i want to [ __ ]
anybody over
all i gots my balls and my word and i
don't break them for nobody
so i [ __ ] searched the kid's thing he
told me he wrote four times me nice to
have some sort of human
response blah blah blah blah
and then i just wrote back this is the
first email i've got from you i'll
gladly give you your money back what's
your address and i haven't heard back
from him
seriously go [ __ ] yourselves
um so anyways what else do i got oh i
didn't announce this last week because
i'm a [ __ ] i'm in the middle of this
this tour
i'm gonna be uh i started a podcast
network
uh and with
al madrigal from minivan men
and a number of other people who uh
don't have podcasts uh so you won't know
who the hell they are but uh it's called
allthingscomedy.com
you should check it out uh we got a
bunch of we got i don't know we got like
eight to ten
cool podcasts on there and um
you know it's kind of how do i explain
you know what
it's just sort of it's it's one for
podcasters if that makes [ __ ] sense
what's happening is these podcasts are
doing really well and now the
businessman's coming in
and he's he's just rounding them all up
and then hey come on to my network okay
here's the deal there [ __ ] johnny
bravo i'll own your podcast you suck a
dick and do your show every week and in
the end i'll make the millions and you
can go [ __ ] yourself
it's the typical behind the music
contract
so me and uh mr madrigal were like well
why don't we just create a co-op
everybody comes in we band together and
the strength of numbers
everybody owns their podcast no funny
[ __ ]
you know whatever listeners you bring in
that's how much money you make
all right no funny business no hidden
hand no rabbit in the hat none of that
[ __ ]
okay we're out of our [ __ ] minds we
created a completely
fair business model for all parties
involved
it's called all things comedy so if you
guys would like to check it out
um of course i don't have any internet
so i can't
i'm trying to remember we got uh we got
uh uh walking the room
we have ari shafir's um we have your
mom's house
you guys probably are listening to some
of these what else do we got come on
bill harland's highway
harlan williams it's great go check it
out go check it out uh minivan men
the monday morning podcast it's an
eclectic mix
of podcasts and everybody still owns
their podcast
nobody's getting [ __ ] over that's a
crazy thing that's not even just show
business just
business in general what i find is
whenever i get in business with somebody
it's always like okay we're getting in
business together
all the receipts and money will go to me
and then i'll tell you
how much we made that's what they always
say to me
all right let's do this this is gonna be
a great collaboration
okay you just sit over there and don't
you worry all monies will come into me
and i'll tell you how much we made go
[ __ ] yourself
every time that's what it's like to play
a comedy club
you know i don't mean people sit in the
[ __ ] room i have somebody standing
back there with a clicker
you know i don't have time for that [ __ ]
i just do a guarantee
pay me this and i will dance like a
monkey all weekend all right that's it
and then you can do whatever boss hog
[ __ ] you want to do sticking [ __ ]
extra chairs in
having a vip section or whatever the
[ __ ] else you want to do
oh bill's in a [ __ ] mood did you guys
watch any of the nfl football yesterday
um i've been missing out on a lot of
football because i've been on the road
and i've been actually going to games i
went to uh
i went to the bengals game or the
bangles
as paul verzi calls it like he he says
the same thing as the girl group
the bengals um i went there and uh what
a great [ __ ] stadium that is
underrated the cincinnati bengal stadium
i i don't even think i
got the name of it it's probably because
i was drinking jameson coming across on
a [ __ ] river boat
at 10 in the morning that's probably why
um
[ __ ] came walking up and i said to
the security guy where's the will call
he's like oh you're really far away from
that
and i go great well which direction is
it in you [ __ ] idiot
um other than that it was a great
experience uh really
really great stadium really intimate
like uh
crowds on top of it and
for some reason this bengals fan in
front of me convinced me to start
heckling the dolphins kicker
who has a highlighted mullet a mullet
with highlights in it i guess is a
better way to describe it
and uh there was a kid behind me so i
never cursed and i was just i was just
sitting there
shredding my voice for nothing i didn't
have any money on the game
i don't give a f i didn't want to see
the dolphins win just because the
patriots in the afc
but um so this is kind of a [ __ ] up
subject
um what's the deal with pink
every [ __ ] year is this like forever
now
every october for an entire month
everybody in the nfl is gonna dress up
like barbie funtime
summer dance [ __ ] uh
winnebago thing i don't know what the
pinky tuscadero and what the
you know what i mean this is the thing
this is it's over this this is something
that you cannot [ __ ] reverse
if you're gonna wear pink for four weeks
all right to raise awareness for breast
cancer
there's no way somebody can come and be
like hey how about just three weeks
you know you can't because it's gonna be
like you don't care about
people suffering from breath cancer
you know i i this is
there's no [ __ ] way to criticize this
without coming off like a cold-hearted
son of a [ __ ] but that's not going to
stop me from trying
am i the only one who finds it like just
a little intrusive
that it's that long that it's just it's
it's a month out of a four-month season
and it's not like they just have a
little bow there they're just [ __ ]
decked out in the [ __ ] it's dad
like who got caught [ __ ] who and this
is what they had to do to make up for it
or is this just like a business move by
the nfl where they're sitting there
going like all right
we can get a lot of ladies watching
if we show that we care about you know
this
as much as we do you know
so this is my solution or my suggestion
can we at least
tone it down can we just start with the
pink
ref whistle does he really have to stick
that thing in his mouth and go
tweety tweet um
i don't do it you know what it is it's
all part of this [ __ ]
slow slide away from everything that
made this country great
nerds and ladies are [ __ ]
i'm not saying they're running [ __ ] but
they're definitely doing the decorating
you know what i mean they're they're in
the driver's seat
they're dictating what the [ __ ] we're
watching oh i'm [ __ ] going full-on
conspiracy theory here
i just you know
the guy's guy is is dead
dead in the water if there's gonna be a
guy's guy
on tv he has to be mocked
you know what i mean it has to be done
in like that office kind of way where
you just [ __ ]
you know he's confident but it's he's
he's betraying and underlying insecurity
now maybe he's just confident
maybe he was just one of those guys who
got laid in the fifth grade
because he just had the [ __ ] gift the
same way
jordan had the gift to play hoop you
know
maybe he's just that guy maybe he's that
guy that all the
ladies wanna bang they wanna touch his
[ __ ] thang
but they don't want to touch yours
right and then what so then you write
the [ __ ] script and then you make him
out to be a douche you know what i for
one don't buy into it
how about you wear it one week who isn't
aware of [ __ ] uh
uh breast cancer at this point who isn't
aware of it
anybody you know i think the nfl because
they're such good businessmen i think
what they're doing
is they're actually you know not enough
women are buying jerseys so they just
have them modeling pink ones for the
entire month acting like they give a
[ __ ]
about finding a cure to this disease so
that women will go out oh my god
i like the pink powder puff dallas
cowboy tony romo one
oh i have a pair of socks that would go
with it so
nicely you know it's [ __ ] football
man
is it like illegal to be a guy now can
you just it's like it's almost just
mocked if you want something to be
[ __ ] hardcore guy
like full on [ __ ] testosterone like
for
some reason it's it's it's just it's
considered uh
i i would say borderline offensive
can you picture ken stabler wearing pink
the steel curtain wearing pink the
doomsday defense
the purple people leaders the [ __ ]
orange crush the overheal gang
how many defenses do i got to bring up
wearing pink they wouldn't have wore
pink they would have said we're not
wearing that sweetheart and they would
have slapped you on your mary tyler
moore ass
and sent you out of the locker room as
they dropped their towels
that was the nfl i grew up with i don't
recognize this nfl
all right everybody running you should
just give them those socks that have
that little ball on the back of the
ankle
you know why don't we have when we have
them wear dresses all through november
for like you know uh sweatshop labor
awareness
you know would be [ __ ] hilarious not
really in an ironic sense
is if those pink uh breast cancer
awareness
jerseys and all that [ __ ] at some point
along
the manufacturing thing are sewn
together by some
child at four in the morning in lake the
philippines
you know what i mean oh the level of
irony in that
wouldn't that be hilarious well i think
it would be
all right i'm kind of um handicapped
this week here because uh
i can't find you know this [ __ ]
internet doesn't work in this goddamn
place
um oh here's the deal by the way if
you're downloading my special first of
all thank you so much and thank you for
everybody who did it i really really
really appreciate it
um it's [ __ ] awesome that you guys
support uh
my specials like that and you come out
to see me
you know like saturday night go bananas
the cincinnati reds are in the playoffs
and people still showed up and they just
taped the game
that does not go unnoticed even by an
arrogant jackass like myself
um all right so i got to let you guys
know that if you didn't receive the
download link to
uh when you email me when you go
seriously
i gave you five dollars seriously just
make sure
that you uh include your paypal receipt
number and
uh special and put special download in
the subject line and just make it easier
for
me to sift through them so that uh
you know i can do right by you you spent
five bucks god damn it you should get
what the [ __ ] you paid for
correct well all right then all right
let's do some advertising for this week
if i can find it scrolling down with my
thumb
where the hell is it come on you [ __ ]
prick
who says prick how old am i
come on yet buy
where the hell is it
is it really easier can somebody please
explain to me how it's easier how these
[ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] iphone [ __ ]
[ __ ]
all right here we go search what happens
do i open an email and then my [ __ ]
ass cheek somehow like
deletes it
there it is all right sorry okay
here we go this [ __ ] 20 seconds of
your life you'll never get back
um all right e-voice everybody if you're
looking uh
if you need help looking more
professional or being more efficient you
should check out evoice
um i've personally received some
ridiculously
uh awesome feedback on twitter from my
listeners
of the show that says uh that the
e-voice thing is helping them get their
business off the ground
helps it to sound professional and all
this stuff this stuff is seriously
um the service i should say is is
seriously
um definitely worth the price of
admission here
by going to www.evoice.com
bill burr you can get a free six month
trial of e-voice
um it helps me
as i can now give out multiple numbers
that will it doesn't help me i don't use
it
why do they always try to get you to say
that you're using it i don't i don't
need this i don't have a business
i'm a [ __ ] solo guy this is for you
guys this is it can help you
give out multiple numbers that will all
come through one cell phone
all right you can have virtual answering
service with multiple accents that make
you sound bigger than you are that's
that great thing that they have where
they actually have
actors like voice over professional
voice over actors
that will make it sound like you have
some smoking hot chick
from [ __ ] cucamonga answering your
phones right there
someone's going to be like well i want
to have a meeting with this guy maybe
that chick's going to show up and by the
time they realize
that she doesn't even exist in your
business world you got them locked in on
eight months of business
um you can transcribe your voicemails to
text or email
basically e-voice makes your life easier
and makes a small business owner look
much bigger
go to www.evoice.com billboard
and get a free six months trial of
e-voice you got to do it
all right and once you get your damn
business going then what do you got to
do
you know it's coming stamps.com
everybody huh
how many times i gotta read to you and
tell you how awesome this is i use this
thing every damn week when i'm sending
out my dvds
um if you would like to never have to go
to the post office again
to be able to have the ability to print
legal
stamps and postage in the safety of your
own apartment
home dwelling tent city wherever the
hell you're at
uh please visit stamps.com um
you would think that i would have this
memorized what the hell are we doing
here um
i'm the worst what else you get a scale
i don't know what else to tell you it's
perfect you don't have to go to the post
office anymore you don't have to wait in
lines you have to deal with their grumpy
attitudes you got the post office when
you within your own goddamn apartment
all right stamps.com
do it live it love it give me feedback
all right
that's it back to the podcast so
so here we are 20 minutes in
i'm dying of of a [ __ ] common cold
hey do you know i was on a plane yes
well what else what else is no i was on
a [ __ ] plane
and uh somebody brought two pitbulls on
the plane on like in like
just both the dogs were on leashes i
didn't know you could do that [ __ ]
the guy got on first and uh
he just walked these two [ __ ]
beautiful dogs on and i was praying to
god he was
sitting next to me that's how much i'm
sold on that breed
as much as everybody everybody's making
their [ __ ] pitbull jokes
it's really like dog racism you know
what i mean
grab your purse there's a pit bull
[Laughter]
but i'm not gonna lie to you they are
scary-looking dogs
they really are they do they they can be
until you get one and then when you see
once you have a [ __ ] pitbull every
time you see one
all you want to do is just go up and pet
the dog and squeeze its [ __ ] thighs
those [ __ ] fullback thighs of this
[ __ ]
um so anyways so i went to the bank the
bengals
game with paul verzi that was uh
franchise number 30. i got two more to
see
the saints in tampa bay i'm going to see
a saints game
in november and then i guess i'll knock
out tampa
bay next year and then then what do i do
huh i've been to every [ __ ] football
stadium every baseball stadium
i'm gonna have to start going to college
and then what
jesus then i go to all the big college
ones and then when i wipe those out
at that point i'll probably be in my 70s
and then i'll just be some creepy
comedian
hanging out at high school football
games oh god
do you think he's going to make it that
far you ever think about that that [ __ ]
are you even gonna make it that far the
fact that it's like 80 degrees
right up until like october 5th and i
don't even know if this has to do with
human beings i have no [ __ ] idea you
know from what i've heard there's been
periods of cooling and warming up
all throughout history but all i know
is that the [ __ ] the [ __ ] be changing
and that there's too many [ __ ] people
i don't know see this is the thing man
this is why i don't know
i should have got married had kids i
gotta i gotta [ __ ] lock this [ __ ]
down i gotta get married and have kids
that's the deal
all right and then i can be just sitting
there focusing on what kind of
stuff is in these fruit loops should we
be like feeding them
this stuff you know meanwhile there's
some [ __ ] black fans sitting out
front i don't even notice it that's
exactly what they want that's what they
want
um you know what that's the podcast for
this week i'm not [ __ ]
i i got i can't do this [ __ ] i don't
have any [ __ ] internet
i can't [ __ ] breathe oh who's a whiny
[ __ ] this week
um dang i gotta hit pause hold on i
gotta [ __ ] blow my nose
all right i'm back okay here we go
it's the [ __ ] worst what the [ __ ] did
i just take the goddamn vitamins
instead of being an [ __ ] hey you know
we actually have a follow-up
um we actually have a follow-up thing
here for the uh that dude remember that
dude a few weeks ago
who had that chick start the rumor that
he was into the weird porn
even though uh it was she who was into
the weird [ __ ] remember that
for those who didn't listen a few weeks
back this guy uh
he's hooking up with this lady and she
says hey why don't you come over we can
watch some porno so he's all excited
you know and he decides to let her
pick the porno which is a very smart
move because god knows if you pick
something too weird you could [ __ ] the
whole evening up
so let her you know pick her like you
know romance porno
you know that's shot with like soft
lighting you know that awful porn that
some women watch
um so that's what he's expecting
and she put on some sort of uh cartoon
where this chick was getting like
[ __ ] you know raped by a a cyclops or
something i don't i can't remember what
the [ __ ] it was
so he flipped out broke up with her and
what does this girl do
rather than going and get some therapy
or just
being okay with the freak that she is uh
she goes around the school and starts
telling everybody that it was he who did
that
[ __ ] with his reputation so uh um he
said what should i do
and i said this is what you do i said
you [ __ ] bring her over you act like
you're getting back together with her
and you just sort of record in the
background and ask her why
she told everybody that that he was the
one that picked out the porn when in
fact it was actually her
and then you got it and then you don't
get back together with her and you say
listen pope of greenwich village right
i got a [ __ ] tape tape that i took
off a [ __ ] dead cop
he pulled that [ __ ] well he did his
version of it all right and here's
here's what he did
okay bill thanks for your advice i took
i took your advice up a level oh i took
your advice up a level
i pretended to get back together with
her and was able to convince her
i had an open mind we made it back to
her place
and i convinced her to go back on the
computer and get another cartoon porno
now this is how you know that this girl
is [ __ ] nuts
is the fact that she absolutely
destroyed this guy's reputation
and then when he goes no no i get it now
can we just get back together and she's
just like yeah let's just get back
together there's no
oh my god i can't believe what i did
i've ruined you
you know why would you even want to get
back together with me after what i did
to you
there's none of that she's just like
okay things are back to normal
psycho um
so anyways i convinced her her to go
back on the computer and get another
cartoon porno i was standing behind her
and took a picture
of her on the com on her computer
i had to sit through the video and got a
[ __ ]
i then went home and printed off the
picture and posted it in her classroom
i was then oh jesus dude i was then
called into the principal
principal's office he was a dude and was
very sympathetic
the only reason i was called in was
because
an old lady teacher reported me the
principal just shrugged and claimed i
was being bullied
and was just trying to clear my name i
acted like i was the victim and he ate
it up
i was about to turn him onto your
podcast but realized it would be
it would make it premeditated bullying
uh she is never going to live it down
but all the girls think i'm an [ __ ]
and guys think i'm a hero so worth it
thanks for your help well
congratulations
well why the [ __ ] do the girls think
you're an [ __ ]
you know i guess because they insert
themselves into the situation where they
there would have been a picture of them
watching a porno but but they
you know they wouldn't have done what
she did
you know that i i'll never understand
bunch of communities have done bits
about that how women [ __ ] can't get
along with each other
but when it comes between you know a
woman and a guy they will support women
blindly
she made she made this guy's life a
living hell jesus dude and you got a
[ __ ] blow job out of it
oh jesus he took it up a notch everybody
all right bill modern football oh this
is because i went off on rugby in
football last year uh hey bill bost
i mean last week hey bill boston's
involved in the creation of modern
american football
be proud all right so he sits there and
he gives me the wikipedia link here
which i'm hoping will open maybe in the
next [ __ ] nine minutes history of
american football
can be traced to early versions of rugby
football
and associations football
well there you go so then why do all
those soccer [ __ ] go like uh
give us [ __ ] like that that was well i
guess because they
it just makes sense that soccer is
football it's a ball and you can only
use your feet
unless you're the goalie um
both games have their origin in how dumb
are we why don't we just call it rugby
yeah that would make more sense if our
version of rugby
those bigger guys hitting each other
harder you know
um anyways both games have their origin
in the varieties of
a football played i don't give a [ __ ]
this is the most boring [ __ ] ever
i hate when somebody sends me a
wikipedia link like they did this
[ __ ] that they went to the bowels of
a library
and found some you know ed rugby versus
nfl football 1862 case you know what i
mean
i don't [ __ ] know that was my call
too
uh dilemma bill would you rather fight
one horse sized
duck or 100 duck sized horses
um oh 100 duck-sized horses
without a [ __ ] doubt oh i'd feel bad
if i broke one of their legs
they're just little little [ __ ]
horsies
i just tip them over i just keep tipping
them over
the [ __ ] duck the size of a horse you
can get killed of course [ __ ] kicks
you in the head you can die
all right they have those little feet
the ducks have those giant [ __ ] web
things
that would be like getting slapped by
the biggest
phone book in the history of mankind
right across the face
at the very least you're going to get a
vicious concussion [ __ ] that 100
duck-sized horses
i can't imagine how hard i would be
laughing as they chased me
you know i when i wait are they as are
they faster than i am
or is it like one of those nightmares
where you're still faster than them but
you can't shake them
for some reason i'll picture myself
fighting these horses in central park
maybe because i'm in new york i would
have that [ __ ] you know
you know like when you were drunk and
you were getting chased by some [ __ ]
person
you know some adult
for whatever [ __ ] reason because
you're having a party or some [ __ ] or
you were on their property
remember that that feeling when you
would start running where you could only
kind of feel your forehead and the top
of your head and the rest of your body
was numb
and you knew it was only a moment of
time before you did a [ __ ] face plant
i think that's how i would feel if i was
getting chased by 100 duck-sized horses
that's what i think everybody that's my
comedic take on that one oh go
this is the worst [ __ ] podcast ever
[ __ ] 36 minutes and how the [ __ ] am i
going to fill these final final [ __ ]
24 minutes
two year breakup bill
this one's pretty [ __ ] and convoluted
but i'm gonna try to make it brief
met my lady in high school almost five
years ago
our first breakup was around the two and
a half year mark despite being broken up
we still had sex went on dates and did a
bunch of
general relationship [ __ ] yeah you're
two codependent people
you should have walked away uh he goes a
few months went by before we made our
relationship official again
a few weeks after that however i found
out she had been [ __ ] some dude
during the hiatus
now don't put hiatus in quotes because
you broke up
you were on hiatus that was fair um
yeah she she did it within the trade
deadline
i was 18 at the time it took it hard
things got ugly between us for a long
time
long story short we stay together for a
year
break up again [ __ ] around while apart
again
and get back together a few months more
goes by before i find out she's been
[ __ ] another dude
during our second hiatus jesus dude
how many times you gonna go back for the
same movie did you go see police academy
seven
because you wanted to see if the little
mousy girl was going to go don't move
dirt bag for the 50th time did you clap
and laugh like a [ __ ] train seal
come on man you're better than this
anyways as you can guess
things get really bad this time
though we haven't got back together
officially this is [ __ ] [ __ ] i
know he says
we still are in an exclusive
relationship
there's literally a mountain of other
[ __ ] that may be slightly
relevant but who gives a [ __ ] here's
where you come in
i'm [ __ ] sick of this [ __ ] but i
can't bring myself to tell
the girl to kick rocks i guess that
means leave
first love lost our virginity to each
other etc
and thoughts of her being with other
people [ __ ] me up even though she
already has been
i'm a huge push [ __ ] and need some
solid advice on how to put this one to
bed thanks
uh [ __ ] yourself all right um
yeah dude what you need to do is
all right you know what's weird before
you have your first [ __ ] girlfriend
before you've ever been in a [ __ ]
relationship
you have this whole [ __ ] life you
have your life granted you're probably
still living at home with your parents
you got to deal with their [ __ ]
brian dinner's ready you got to deal
with that [ __ ] right
but generally speaking you have your
[ __ ] life you know you're playing
street hockey you're going out have
drinking beers
you're [ __ ] going to games you're
doing whatever the [ __ ] you're doing
then all of a sudden you get your first
girlfriend right and suddenly i
find how wonderful my life right
um and then all of a sudden your life
just becomes about that
especially if you're codependent and
you're gonna stop doing the other
[ __ ]
and then all of a sudden you [ __ ]
break up and you can't even remember
what the [ __ ] you did
before you met this person right you
feel you feel lost
you feel hopeless you feel worthless you
don't even think life is [ __ ] worth
living
all that is obviously going to miss this
person you got to remember you got you
got to build your life back
up you gotta you gotta
[ __ ] sit down and be like what the
[ __ ] that i used to enjoy doing
before i met that [ __ ] nightmare with
the vagina
you know what i used to like to do and
just start doing that [ __ ]
all right get out there be [ __ ]
social and look it's gonna suck
for a good six weeks
after six weeks there'll be enough time
and this is the thing too
don't be talking to her during that six
weeks
all right women have this unbelievable
ability to
sense when you're starting to get your
[ __ ] together after a breakup
and they will call you 1-800 mind [ __ ]
and they will stir your [ __ ] up
and they'll set you a week and a half
behind
all right don't don't [ __ ] do that
all right
you you you you walk away like de niro
and heat
that's what you got to do on this one
just [ __ ] walk away it's over
it's done go [ __ ] yourself it's it you
don't have to say that stuff to it but
just it's over
just be like i have to figure out who i
am again
and then that's it sniffle and walk away
and just accept the fact that it's going
to suck for a good six weeks but every
day is going to get a little easier
all right at the end of [ __ ] six
weeks you know
you'll be fine you'll still miss her
every once in a while but don't go back
to that [ __ ] it's [ __ ] misery you
know it's misery
all right you got a man up and this is a
[ __ ] lesson you really have to learn
in life or
you're gonna end up staying with this
girl or repeat this [ __ ]
process with somebody else that you
shouldn't be with and one of these days
you're going to knock them up and then
your life's really going to suck
all right so stop being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
there's plenty of broads
out there you know that's it
join a gym go to a [ __ ] game go
travel just go do something that doesn't
involve her something that you can
[ __ ] look forward to
all right and there you go and that's it
i hope that helps you all right
all right last week last week i was
laughing my ass off reading this thing
where this guy was trying to claim
um that that sleep sex [ __ ]
you know that basically he's asleep and
he just starts having sex
with his [ __ ] uh girlfriend
and he's completely asleep he's totally
asleep i i just
evidently this is somebody says hey bill
this does exist
this does happen to me at least a dozen
times a year that's what somebody wrote
in
um listen this one
bill i feel compelled to write to you
this email after hearing the monday
morning podcast this morning
i know the guy's sleep sex story sounds
insane but i can tell you that it's a
hundred percent a real thing
hear me out this is so [ __ ] nuts
somebody else told me that there was
somebody
who [ __ ] was asleep woke up didn't
wake up
got up like a [ __ ] zombie got in the
car
drove across town murdered somebody
and came back and got off because they
were asleep
okay you can't drive a car when you're
[ __ ] asleep
this is [ __ ] i i don't i don't give
a [ __ ]
if there's a scientific name are your
eyes open then you're awake
well you're driving down the street with
[Music]
with your [ __ ] eyes closed
you know are these these people like
supernatural beings are they witches
what are they doing
why are they having sex why don't they
wake up and do like [ __ ] uh they
start you know
scrubbing the floor why do they always
go do something fun
like get laid or kill somebody that's
annoying them how come they never do
anything miserable
oh my god i got [ __ ] you know i was
[Music]
i've reshingled the roof from my
neighbor
yeah it's [ __ ] this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] all you guys
i'll read it i'll try to have an open
mind here's another guy
who suffers from uh getting laid while
he's sleeping
in college i was dating a girl who would
do the same thing
i started spending the night at her
place which was closer to campus
than my dorm one night i came back
really late after driving back to
college from home i walked in
i heard loud moaning like someone was
having sex
thinking she was cheating on me i bust
into a room to beat the [ __ ] out of
whoever she was [ __ ]
which is hilarious why would you beat
the [ __ ] out of that person unless they
knew you and knew that you were in a
relationship
the guy's just doing what he's supposed
to be doing he's trying to get laid
you should go in there and [ __ ] call
the girl a [ __ ] and then leave
miss direct and anger anyways he goes i
walked in only to find her by herself
in bed naked from the waist down
fingering the hell out of herself
so he goes so i walked over thinking i
could get in on the action
and her eyes were closed and she
wouldn't respond to me
talking to her dude what kind of [ __ ]
blair witch
uh the exorcist this is [ __ ] creepy
you walk in her eyes are closed she's
like a zombie state
finger blasting herself and your first
thought is hey maybe i can get in on the
action
[Laughter]
that right there just shows the weakness
of a man the fact that he can go from
that level of rage i'm gonna beat the
[ __ ] out of whoever's banging my girl to
two seconds later like hey
maybe i can help you out with that later
little lady
um anyways once she finished she seemed
to fall asleep immediately
thinking this was crazy i woke her up
and asked her what the [ __ ] was going on
she admitted that this happened
sometimes not very often but sometimes
and she never told me about it because
it was embarrassing
i was like okay whatever i never really
thought about it again
really you saw something that bizarre
were like
all right okay you know
then he never thought about it again
that sounds like that would be like so
disturbing to see somebody in a
zombified state
fingering themselves i don't think i
mean
just me picturing what that looks like i
don't know if i'll ever be able to
forget it
um anyway
now let me get to uh [ __ ] i'm gonna
sneeze god damn it
hang on a second all right i'm back
i'm back here um yeah like i don't think
i could ever get that that thought out
of my head
well i just kind of shook it off and
continued on he said now let's get to
where
i say sleep sex is real about three
weeks later i was spending the night at
her place again
and i woke up to her talking in her
sleep oh my god
dude this is the creepy sh is she
speaking in tongues
666 on a [ __ ] forum this sounds like
one of those the
uh i gotta know what the name of the
[ __ ] movie is
um anyways
what the hell was i
three weeks later i woke up she was
talking her sleep but talking like she
was having sex
saying [ __ ] like yeah [ __ ] me
and stuff but she was just talking not
doing anything else
so she's sitting up in bed
having a [ __ ] conversation her eyes
[ __ ] like rolling around in her
[ __ ] head this is the creepiest [ __ ]
ever
do you guys sleep in like a pyramid is
she like like
is she like [ __ ] cursed this sounds
like some [ __ ] that would only happen
like in an indiana jones movie
um so he goes so i decided to wake her
up and let her know what she was doing
i leaned over and kind of shook her
softly you know saying
hey wake up wake up instead of waking up
she rolled toward me
ah the zombie
ah [ __ ] me [ __ ] me
this is the [ __ ] exorcist
ah suck your dick um
oh god i always forget i'm in new york i
can't imagine what my [ __ ]
[ __ ] neighbors are thinking right now
uh instead of waking up she rolled
toward me
and put her hands down my pants and
started jerking me off and kissing me
see this is where it goes out the window
this is where it goes out it's a jerky
dude
this is where it goes out the [ __ ]
window for me if you're asleep
how do you know where this where
everything is
oh i'm asleep and i'm walking out to the
garage not bumping into anything
grabbing the keys
i gotta go kill the neighbor give me a
[ __ ] break this is the dumbest [ __ ]
i've ever heard in my life
this isn't real
so she rolls to us that's jerking me off
kissing me and then still in her
in her sleep said are you going to [ __ ]
me or what
and he goes well [ __ ] how can i turn
that down
how could you turn it down because her
[ __ ] eyes are rolling up in her head
dude isn't this like a form of rape
if she's asleep and you're banging her i
mean it's just
what if what if you didn't know her she
walks up back me back me
walking around her [ __ ] pajamas out
in the lawn pulled up in a car
this is the creepiest [ __ ] i've ever
read about in my my five years of doing
this podcast this is the creepiest [ __ ]
ever
this is linda blair
linda blair is a porn star so she goes
you're going to [ __ ] me or what and if a
guy goes well [ __ ] how can i turn that
down
i started to take my pants off and her
still
sleeping started stripping in the bed
see this all has like a i'm awake kind
of thing or possessed one or the other
he goes we started going at it but the
whole time her eyes were still closed
but it was like she was awake
grabbing onto me kissing me moaning it
was totally crazy
then the craziest thing happened
so this girl was one of those more
reserved types
we never really had dirty sex dude if
you bang this girl in the ass while
she's [ __ ]
in this zombified state um
i don't know what to tell you he goes we
never really had dirty sex or anything
it was still really good but nothing out
of the ordinary except tonight
all of a sudden while we're going at it
she flips over
onto her knees and says put in my ass oh
my god
dude [ __ ] you guys did you guys all get
together and just say let's [ __ ] with
bill
and let's just write the craziest
[ __ ] emails ever dude is there some
sort of website where you guys are doing
this i this is not
real this isn't real
he goes what the [ __ ] i about [ __ ]
fell over
never had we even talked about it or
anything and all of a sudden she was
doing
things she had never done at least with
me without even seeming like it was new
she just acted like it happens all the
[ __ ] time dude if you do this
why don't you wake her up and be like
sweetheart just to let you know that
you're asleep right now
telling me to put my dick in your ass i
you know are you comfortable with going
back to sleep and letting me do that
i'm just checking
all right nighty night um anyways it was
one of the craziest nights of sex i ever
had dude you're a [ __ ]
creep
you're a [ __ ] creep dude you're a
[ __ ] creep okay if i was with
somebody and they were a zombie
i would wake them up all right
you had [ __ ] anal sex with this girl
when she was like awake asleep
awake asleep whatever the [ __ ] the
medical version of this is [ __ ]
insane
uh the next morning she woke up and
didn't mention a thing about it at all
all day so i finally decided to bring it
up
oh that's a good move hey by the way
last night when you were sleeping but
kind of were awake but we're asleep uh
i i put in your ass if you wondered why
uh you know you felt a little weird this
morning yeah
because i oh jesus he goes i told her
what happened
and at first she was pretty pissed yeah
i would think so
but then after talking about it for a
few minutes
she admitted that this had happened a
few times before
where she's had sex in her sleep with
someone including her sister's boyfriend
wow that's what he wrote and i would
have said that anyways
dude so the boyfriend banged her while
she was sleeping her sister's boyfriend
that this
is like rape guys this is [ __ ] nuts
she's not in a place where she can say
no she's dreaming about something else
if this [ __ ] even exists this is the
creepiest [ __ ] email ever
oh and it keeps going she started crying
and saying she didn't know what to do so
i offered to go with her to a therapist
and at least approach the topic with the
professional
well aren't you just a [ __ ] great guy
after you banged her in the ass while
she was
sleeping the therapist said
she may have sex omnia
that was the term she used seriously
look it up
or a sleep disorder where a person
actually has sex
in their sleep yeah go [ __ ] your sex
omnia
that now no [ __ ] you i'm not i'm not
buying this
the therapist said it's more common than
people think
no it isn't no it isn't none of my
friends have this story they would have
told me
and that it's treatable only in some
cases
she got on some medication it seemed to
help a little
but there were a few times when [ __ ]
happened in her sleep
and know those times i did not bang her
in her sleep
after that one time it just didn't feel
right since it was something
she had no control over really
it took you after that first time
so instead i would wake her up that's
what you should have done the first time
jesus christ anyways just wanted to send
you this email so you didn't think the
sleep sex guy was a total psycho
go [ __ ] yourself i downloaded your
latest special and loved it catch you
later well thank you for downloading
this special uh as far as your uh
chivalrous axe after you [ __ ] went
anal on that girl i don't know about
that man
wow well there you go people that was
worth the price of admission huh
i still don't believe it sex omnia
at the very least it's not common i i
would have heard something about it
okay i'm down like i'm acting like i'm a
doctor right now i
i'm down i i'm in the medical field
i'm up to my knees in it i would have
heard something i would have heard some
sort of study but i i don't bite
i don't bite okay all right
let's do some final advertising here for
the week and then we're gonna [ __ ]
end it
mercifully end this podcast um a couple
of quickies here
um amazon.com holiday shopping is
starting up
so be sure to visit amazon amazon banner
on the podcast page of billboard.com
it's a huge help as amazon will kick
back a percentage of your
uh your spend
percentage of what you spend if you go
through my banner first it helps support
the podcast as well as the wounded
warrior project
um i love the last bullet point is thank
you
gamefly.com everybody hey do you want to
play 8 000 video games of course you do
um click on the gamefly banner for free
two-disc
two-week free trial 347 people did that
last month so thank you
for that and hopefully you enjoyed the
service uh
you want your free two-week trial go to
www.gamefly.com
or the banner ad on my podcast page for
your free trial and enjoy all the video
games you can play
[Music]
and that is it ladies and gentlemen that
right there is the podcast for this week
um
so let me recap what i'm hyping this
week uh i have a book come on coming out
tomorrow called called cheat
the the man's guide to uh infidelity
and it's based on our short film called
cheat if you buy the book you get a link
to the movie you get to see the movie
and the whole thing will make sense it's
completely over the top it's
completely in your face uh it's [ __ ]
hilarious um
i wrote it with robert kelly and joe
derosa the teen idol sensation from the
opium anthony program
um you know after all those years of
sitting around
not doing [ __ ] we actually made a movie
and wrote a book you may like it you may
not but
go [ __ ] yourself we at least completed
the project my special you people are
all the same is available for download
at billboard.com cost you five bucks um
you'll get a link to download the
special you have five days to download
it
five days one two three four five five
days so you know if you're
traveling that gives you time to get
home and we initially only had it up for
24 hours
not realizing that some people would buy
it and then fly on a plane do some
[ __ ]
so my apologies for that inconvenience
to other people
but in general i think it worked worked
really well and
i swear to god man i know i joke around
and everything but uh that really means
a lot to me that you guys supported my
uh
my special and i was glad i was able to
give it to you for five bucks
it all [ __ ] worked out for everybody
you know you don't get [ __ ] i don't
get [ __ ] it's all good
and thank you to louis ck for coming up
with that um
and also if you want to buy a hard copy
version of it
um that'll be more like around christmas
time
and that'll also be available on
billboard.com i'm just kind of getting
the logistics of that down
and um and then of course i will be
selling them at my shows
coming up around the holidays i'll be
giving you guys more information about
that
also the new podcast um
whatever you want to call it network
allthingscomedy.com check it out
check out all the podcasts are on there
ari shafir has a new cd
out um that guy really i'm telling you
man
every time i see him like that guy's the
next guy he's uh it's it's
always great to see somebody like
breaking out of the pack and that guy's
really
turning the corner and i think he's on
his way to doing something so
if he's performing in your area go see
him now so you can say i saw him when
and check out his new uh comedy cd also
uh [ __ ] tom segora
from your mom's your mom's house podcast
has a new cd out called uh
white girls and cornrows you should
check it out the guy's absolutely
hilarious i did his podcast last
week he's also part of the network and
that's it that's it for this week
everybody thank you so much for
listening
um oh and oh billy twinkle toes i'm
going to be on inside the nfl this week
if you can believe it i have no idea
what i'm going to do on it um
other than phil not qualified because
everybody there has pretty much played
the game or went to broadcasting school
and i'm just some obnoxious [ __ ]
comedian but uh they're going to have me
on
and that's going to be on showtime i
imagine that's going to be airing this
weekend maybe friday
saturday i have no idea but um
i'll definitely be putting out a
facebook and twitter blast
um that is it that's the podcast and
thank you to everybody who came out to
cincinnati
all right i'm going on too long go [ __ ]
yourselves i'll see you